Democratic leaders in Washington say
they're feeling very concerned after
last night's debate but what did viewers
think well Dave Portnoy isn't
technically the president but he is El
Presidente he's the founder and head guy
at barstool sports
he came on last week to assess that
debate he's back tonight Dave Portnoy
joins us so Dave thanks for coming on
you you you weren't it super impressed
by Bloomberg last week I think it's fair
to say you used the word vomit several
times in your description ha did you
reassess your view after watching last
night I don't know if I really I don't
think anybody came out you know looking
good yesterday
you blended in I'm not sitting here and
single him out I mean every this was a
this was a war this is like anchorman
when every news station has a weapon and
they're just hitting each other with it
it was sort of embarrassing again you
know I don't know if you watch that
they're all raising their hand they're
all screaming over each other I
absolutely do not know a simple question
why can't they turn off the microphones
when their time is up you know you do it
on a ton of game shows your times up
your microphones off I could win this
debate because I would just never shut
up I would never be intimidated to stop
talking if you just talked the longest
and the loudest eventually you get the
floor but honestly I tweeted this out if
I was an alien and I landed on earth and
this is who are supported lasers were
the people competing to be the president
I would invade I mean it's embarrassing
and I don't know it's any different
about publicans or Democrats but this
process well I mean there has to be a
better way to do they just scream at
each other and look like [ __ ] so it
looks like a kindergarten with no
teachers in it it's disgusting oh so I
got two questions one why would you
invade cuz they look so weak they'd be
easy to take over or you'd invade for
their own good or both I would probably
invade both for their own good but
they're all gonna be looking at each
other
battling each other and they can walk
right by them into the White House I
mean it literally insane these are
supposed to be intelligent people
screaming at each other and by the way
I'd also just lie I would never shut up
and I would lie I just throw stats big
nobody knows you can say anything nobody
knows in real time if is true and by the
time tomorrow rolls around a couple
stats are checked yeah you know Biden
can't go out and say everybody in
America was killed by guns last year
because we're still alive but unless you
screw up that badly nobody knows it's
just a shout fest I mean that's all it
is that's what politics are Raiders well
the moderate your office the moderator
okay so what is that shouldn't they be
shouldn't they be keeping control Tucker
it's really simple
shut the mic off you have 30 seconds and
then you press the button you mics off
you scream out of there is that
revolutionary how hard is that to do hey
buddy your time's up beep you get muted
I on ESP on that show around the horn
they do it all the time your time is up
beep you can't talk anymore if I'm the
only one to think of this instead they
just scream at each other it's insane
do you you got some lab guys in your
office what I mean you don't put up with
this kind of stuff do you well we this
is what it looks like but here's the
thing I want to put our guys running the
country we're idiots everyone looks at
us and says parcel sports frat humor
they yelling at each other locker room
environment these are the people who
criticize us these are the people
they're worse than we are
oh by the way I want to say this I'm
wearing an Armani suit that's one of the
reasons I came on because if Bernie gets
elected I don't want to steal it from me
so I want to get some use for me if
Elizabeth Warren gets elected by the way
you're going straight to prison they're
all come out but it's gonna be too busy
again I'm smarter than their they'll
just yell at each other and I'll just go
around the corner
honestly shut the microphones off and
this isn't just Democrat Republican they
just scream at each other make stuff up
and who knows everyone just looks around
in the audience like what just happened
how do I pick what happened how could
anybody pick between these people how
one of the great debate assessments I've
heard Dave Portnoy El Presidente
barstool sports great to see you thank
you